as the NFL season gets ready to kick off
yes it's almost time one of the league's
top stars continues to inspire kids far
off the playing field last season tight
end Martellus Bennett helped lead the
New England Patriots to that incredible
Super Bowl victory
now he's suiting up with the Green Bay
Packers and at the same time he's
rolling out a football themed comic book
just part of his ongoing effort to spark
creativity in kids Jan Crawford has the
story over nine seasons Martellus
Bennett has established himself as one
of the top tight ends in the NFL and
when the Patriots were down 19 points in
the fourth quarter of Super Bowl 51
[Applause]
Tom Brady turned to Bennett to help
mount the biggest comeback in Super Bowl
history after the game Bennett's
daughter Jett joined him to address the
media giving the football world a
glimpse of life inside the imagination
agency a multimedia company
headquartered in the basement of
Bennett's colorfully decorated home just
north of Chicago there and it creates
videos rights books and comes up with
ideas hoping to make kids like his
daughter believe impossible I feel like
well imagination you cannot create
solution for me it's the whole idea of
the imagination agency is to get kids to
dream bigger was fun Bennett also brings
his message directly to communities
where he feels it's most needed
basically I'm the black Walt Disney
right this summer he visited with kids
from Chicago's South Side where more
than 400 people have been killed so far
this year a place not too different than
the Houston neighborhood where Bennett
grew up where we come from you know they
roll you a basketball I'll give you a
football and say good luck I don't want
to see more black presidents or more
black CEOs or more black animators or
more black kids coming up with tech
ideas and things like that Bennett told
the group that growing up football
actually was his plan B and that while
many of his classmates were getting in
trouble he was focusing on the future
when I look at those kids I see myself I
see my friends that I grew up with I see
the crowd that was at my school
hopefully there when they look at me
they see themselves and what they can
become as well the imagination agency
has already come out with one animated
movie and it's now working on turning
Bennett's first book hey AJ it's
Saturday based on his daughter into a
cartoon series a second book in the AJ
series comes out later this year all
right there's also a line of children's
shoes in the works in collaboration with
the chicago-based company bucket feet
proceeds will go to help build a
playground in its hometown of Houston
people expect me to be good at football
I've been good at football since I was
kid I expect me a bear to do that but
people are expect you to write a
children's book or make an app or
where kids can relate and they lovin is
really really really really good the
great thing about football is that gives
you a platform where you can make a
bigger impact to stand on some guys
shout and their platform and some guys
whisper and Bennett is using his
platform to make a statement about what
matters long after he leaves the field
for CBS this morning Saturday Jan
Crawford it's a great statement it
really is and I've heard so many
athletes they've told me I want to use
my platform they don't all get to do it
so I love to see what he's doing right
now
really great really great to see